the sentencing of former USA Gymnastics
dr. Larry Nasser resumes Monday the
judge extended the sentencing so that
more of Nasser's 140 victims can get the
chance to deliver their impact
statements face-to-face after they were
sexually abused under the guise of
medical treatment dr. Jon LaPook has
more from the Michigan courthouse
following a fourth day of powerful
confrontations I am here to tell you
that I will not rest until every last
trace of your influence on this sport
has been destroyed like the cancer it is
Team USA gymnast Aly Raisman made a
surprise appearance to confront the man
who abused her
Larry Nasser Larry you do realize now
that we this group of women you so
heartlessly abused over such a long
period of time are now a force and you
are nothing
race men then addressed the new head of
USA Gymnastics Carrie Perry
unfortunately you've taken on an
organization that I feel is rotting from
the inside we need an independent
investigation of exactly what happened
what went wrong and how can be avoided
for the future Jordyn Wieber another
member of that team came forward Friday
to speak publicly for the first time my
parents trusted USA Gymnastics and Larry
now start to take care of me and we were
betrayed by both and now the lack of
accountability from u.s. AG USOC and
Michigan State have caused me and many
other girls to remain shameful confused
and disappointed Nasser treated
Olympians like Reis Minh and Weber for
USA Gymnastics in addition he worked for
Michigan State University where he saw a
softball player Tiffany Thomas Lopez one
of four athletes we spoke with who are
among the victims addressing the court
Thomas Lopez says after being abused by
NASA from 1999 to 2001 she spoke with a
supervising trainer and she says here we
are you're gonna cause a riff you're
going to make a lot of people
uncomfortable you can do this you know
she made sure to tell me like you can do
this you can file a complaint but this
is going to be big news
what's gonna happen to him that's what
it was just all about like you know yeah
him and in representing the school she
decided to drop it and soon left
softball because of her injuries for CBS
this morning Saturday dr. Jon LaPook
Lansing Michigan
[Applause]